hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the finals of the Magnus
Invitational we are at Game four and the
Nakamura needs a win to get back into
the match he already did it once in game
two now can he do it once again in Game
four with the white pieces no less so
again we have d4 from Hikaru and Knight
to f6 and again we're gonna go into the
Queens gambit declined c4 e6 nine of
three and d5 the Queens gambit declined
is on the board and Knight to c3 so
let's see who's gonna switch it up or
are both of them satisfied with the
games that we've already played we have
c6 my magnets going for the semi Slav
Bishop to g5 and now Knight B to d7 now
we have a three and now Queen to a5
magnets goes for the Canberra Springs
variation which I think it's been quite
a while since we've seen it on this
channel especially in top-tier
tournaments but okay Knight to d2 not
allowing this night to be pinned also
preventing the this Knight from jumping
to e4 sorry about that and we have D
captors and C for the main move here is
Bishop to b4 however Magnus goes for D
captures on c4 instead which has been
played quite a lot in 2020 and Nakamura
goes for the for the obvious choice as
now you opened up the attack towards the
bishop by capturing and c4 so Bishop
captures on f6 Knight captures and only
now do you recapture on c4 we have
Knight captures on c4 you could also
capture with the bishop but the bishop
will be developed e to end the night
from c4 attacks the Queen wall also
prevents this Bishop from being
developed to d6 which is kind of useful
in hindering blacks development so Queen
back to c7 and now Bishop to e2 Nakamura
prepares the castle with Bishop to e7
and a3 now taking away the before square
from blacks pieces also preparing before
we have castles by Magnus and now b4 as
planned we have looked to d8 now that
makes sense as the Queen is still on the
ones who white might have to worry about
ideas like ePHI which could free the the
light square bishop and adjust castles
here now and there is one game where
Bishop to d7 was played but here we have
b6 by Magnus and it
as of move 13 that we have a completely
new game so Nakamura continues with
Bishop to f3 grabs hold of this diagonal
prevents Carlson from executing c5 so
Bishop the a6 first attacks the knight
here we have Queen to b3 defending while
also connecting rooks and now rotate the
ca the rook is now not on the eighth
square anymore and you are now ready to
push c5 we look a to c1 and now just
developing the rook also the queen is on
c7 so it it doesn't make sense and
Magnus just pushes c5 as a Hikaru
allowed it so d captures and c5 and here
Bishop captures and c4 first Magnus
wants to trade as many pieces as
possible Queen captures and B captors in
c5 now and while you could continue just
capturing here first Knight to a4 by
Hikaru and Knight to d7 adding another
defender to the c5 pawn and here Hikaru
is very happy with his position
obviously problem is Magnus only needs a
draw to win the match so if you go for
someone like Queen a6 put pressure on
the pawn here just a nice active move
now black is unable to capture due to
this then Queen to be 8 is very strong
and again if you capture then black is
very happy just trading everything
character scalpers captures and we have
this our position where both players
have an a pawn but black has it nicely
defended and no problems for black so he
car needs a move that keeps the game
alive he tries Queen to b5 instead and
the Magnus now needs needs to find a
move that basically neutralizes all of
he carves threats now 25 is one such
move that that does so but Magnus
instead goes for Queen to b8 and he says
I'm not worried about anything here now
let's just trade Queens and I will be
very happy to hold this end game and he
curses all right but by doing so I will
also grab a pawn so Queen actress on b8
we have rook after sandy 8 and now just
be captures on c5 so not Knight captures
and c5 allowing more trades Hikaru keeps
some more pieces on the board but this
also means that he keeps the knight on
the edge of the board but he does have
an extra pawn so let's see what what can
the past see Pandu
look D to see it from Magnus and now c6
he car starts pushing his passport we
have Knight to e5 now with a double
attack on the pawn here and just rook
the c3 by hikari preparing rook F to c1
to double up on the C file magnus grabs
on f3 with check we have G captures in
the now King to f8 Magnus starts
bringing the King into the game which
says that he and he also says to Hikaru
you cannot bring your knight into the
game because I'm just gonna trade and
I'm very happy with my position also you
can to do something like the 95 and rook
captures and ceases because you have
this check which would win the rook but
the Magnus of course would adjust
capture and then start bringing his King
into the game and he would be very happy
you can double up here and maybe maybe
even win the pawn back so no problems
for Magnus so he karo instead goes rook
to d1 and now cutting off the the black
King and also preparing a beautiful
trick Carson goes King to e8 and we have
worked the d7 by Hikaru trying to trick
Magnus into going rook captures here the
kind of trade rooks but here he Carl had
rook captures on e7 prepared which
basically leaves him up a whole night so
Magnus of course spots the trick he
plays Bishop to f6 gets the bishop out
of harm's way with tempo as the rook is
under attack
so rook to c5 and only now does Magnus
grab the phone we have rook captures
rook captures on e7 now by Hikaru and
rook captures on c5 we have Knight
captures on c5 and now we have this
position where he car is still up upon
but it's a passed a pawn which could
prove prove to be a bit difficult to
defend
so Magnus goes to Buster back to e7 that
puts pressure on the knight and Knight
to e4 now and f5 now we have Knight back
to g3 and the g6 now Magnus has to start
improving the position of the King and
keep an eye on that a3 path bone so a4
Hikaru starts pushing it and King to f7
now and here we have 92 trying to bring
the knight into the game the other way
around King to f6 and now rook to a6
now it's a question whether you just
start pushing the pawn or do you try to
create some threats
Hikaru goes to rock the a6 for is going
for night
before to put pressure on the e6 pawn so
rook the b2 by Magnus and now Knight to
f4 Magnus even allows this sorry not
Knight the d4 Knight to f4 and here just
came to f7 not allowing this point to
fall with Church
Magnus is basically inviting inviting
this capture because if Knight captures
here then you get Bishop to h4 and you
go after the f2 pawn then the e3 pawn
then well you're gonna grab a lot of
pawns and you will be very happy
so Nakamura ignores this eise exponent
he goes 4/9 to D three attacks Carlson's
rook and now rook the a2
cousin just puts a room behind the
passed pawn we have looked at a seven
and the King to have sex not allowing
the bishop to be pinned and now f4 which
is very strong as it prevents the the
King from moving so you might you know
it could be very dangerous for example
if the bishop moves you can see that the
rook is controlling the entire seventh
rank and you know if with the pawns
controlling this if the knight gets all
the way let's say to eat it could be
checkmate but that's a lot of moves so
Bishop to d6 by Magnus and now rook the
a6 is going after the Bishop King b7 and
now Knight to e5 and now this Knight is
an extremely strong piece here if if you
don't eliminate it it's just gonna be
there forever you're not gonna be able
to move all your pieces a lot so Magnus
says I am very happy to hold this rook
and pawn and game being a pawn down so
Bishop captures we have F captures and
King d7 and now he carrots to find how
to create how to create threats here and
how to start the pushing this point of
the board so here you go King to g2 if
you try something like rook the a7 check
to go after the h7 pawn just King c6 and
after rook captures here you're gonna
capture this point and you will be very
very happy holding this if you go after
rook here King d5 you're gonna grab this
pawn and this is all very fine for
Magnus so King g2 akaru not interested
in parting with his pawn here g5 by
Magnus we have looked the d6 check and
came back to e7 Hikaru goes back rook to
a6 and Magnus says I'm very happy with a
draw here as I
in the magic if we draw the game so a5
Hikaru starts pushing the pawn and the
magnet starts pushing on the Kings side
we have h5 look back to d6 wait to check
and we have a repetition King is 7 but
now a 6 so Hikaru got this pawn to a6
but now the question is how do you get
it
further up the board because Magnus is
not moving his rook from behind the
passed pawn so we have age 4 here my
Magnus and now rook the rook the b6 just
trying to create some some threats here
rook to b7 check followed by a 7 is an
idea so King to d7 and now rook back to
d6 check now if you go for this check
then just kink the c6 and you cannot
push the pawn since the rook hangs so
look back the d6 with check King to e7
and now the problem is he coral is
already done - one minute and some
twenty seconds whereas cousin has I
think around two and a half minutes so
Hikaru really burning a lot of time
trying to figure out how to go about
this
with h3 and now just rook the a5 by
Magnus also puts pressure on the pawn
here of course here and you're not
interested in capturing that so f4 by
Hikaru
and now g4 by Magnus and now if you
capture here then you just give black to
connected pass pawns you don't want to
do that so look back to b6
but now look the a2 with check we have
King the h1 and now rook the a1 with
check with King to g2 rook the a2 with
check and here
Kings the f1 by Hikaru now Magnus
repeats rook to e1 with check King g2
and now look the ATO with check and it
was in this position that the the
players agree to a draw as if there is
no way to make further progress if he
Carl gets greedy and tries to go
somewhere like this then the H point
will just Queen so you don't really have
an option you have to repeat moves and
just continue getting out of checks so
by drawing this game Magnus wins the
match and by this he wins the Magnus
cross an invitational tournament and
before we forget here are the final
standings after the tournament ended so
Magnus Carlsen wins first place and also
the price of $70,000 followed by he
carvings second with $45,000
then ding lurin in third and Fabiano in
fourth now sharing 30,000 I thought it
would be it'd be a bigger price for
third and fourth but since I it was a
knock out and they bought we were
eliminated in the semifinals it doesn't
make sense that it's equal then in 50 on
the pony issue with 22 and a half then
ali reza fuchsia with 20 onigiri with 17
and a half and a maxi marshal a graph in
eighth place with $15,000 so that that
sums up to total prize fund of twenty
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
which still makes it the big biggest
ever online chess event in chess history
of the world yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you enjoyed
my short coverage of this event probably
probably going to return to the poem or
fish taco we're gonna check up on wheel
watch s0 and well pretty much everything
else that's happening and it's just roll
we have the nation's Cup coming up so
we're gonna check that out as well
but I might take a day or two off to you
know relax a bit now after this event
has finished nobody on and this is the
third time Magnus defeats Hikaru
Nakamura in D in the online online
finals of some first thing he beat him
in twenty sixteen speeches championship
then I believe in 2018 speech Chess
Championship and now in 2020 the the
Magnus Invitational so tough break for
Hikaru but there is always next time
yeah once again I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Neil's wild called
Nilsson Blair Barnes a Bryce Foster and
the Donald Kinsey for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing whatever I feel like
continuing most likely about yeah thank
you all I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday